a lesbian couple is suing the Trump
administration and the US Conference of
Catholic Bishops after they were denied
the opportunity to become foster parents
to an unaccompanied refugee child the
women claimed they were unlawfully
turned down for religious reasons
because the Texas program takes federal
money joining us now from New York to
discuss the situation is from the
Catholic League of course President Bill
Donohue from the Catholic League bill
what's going on in this case because
this couple says they were told
basically they are not there they're
coupledom is not mirroring that of the
Holy Family which is what the Catholic
organization told me right there was one
allegation one woman denied that and
let's say it is who cares look this is a
pattern all across the country
ACLU suing Catholic hospitals to make
them perform abortions you have gay
couples trying to crash Catholic
institutions forced to care or whatever
it is they've lost every single time in
the case of this case in Texas that law
was passed last year protecting the
right of faith-based initiatives to to
exercise their doctrinal prerogatives
and that would mean that Catholic
agencies which do not believe in
same-sex marriages do not have to allow
a lesbian couple to have their care and
at the federal level we have faith-based
institutions for decades it's just as
long as you don't and got involve
yourself in inherently religious
activities such as forcing the kids to
go to Mass and prayer services and
things that would make some people
nervous people have a phobia about
religion then you're okay so they know
they're gonna lose it's a matter of gay
bullying and harassment if you want to
know the truth
so presumably this couple if they wanted
to foster a child there's probably no
shortage of children in the United
States or certainly in Texas I would
imagine that they could probably find
that they would be welcome to foster
these children so your point is that
they're going to these various Catholic
organizations their shopping them their
shopping at the ACLU and in particular
is doing this
these are gay activists they try to act
like as if they're not they're gay
activists they're trying to shove their
secular values down our throat you know
it's when the church gets too
we say what about church and state it
works the other way more often than not
when the state is encroaching on a
religious institution which is why we
have these religious liberty protection
laws all over the states it's precisely
because of secular secular militants
trying to shove their way in and tend to
basically neuter Catholic institutions
once you take out the catalyst city of a
Catholic institution it's now secular
they can go to other religions which are
okay with this they can go to secular
and public alert submissions
yeah the Lutheran's do a lot sure the
Unitarians would love the right well the
Lutheran's do a lot of resettlement as
well to get a big federal grants right
so that's also an issue in Massachusetts
they basically did away with Catholic
adoptions correct and in other states
Catholic adoption agencies are basically
shut down because of these lawsuits
correct it varies by state and there and
some some states have been that the
Catholics have been willing to
capitulate this is not a subtle issue
but if anything the law is on our side
particularly with the states that
they're that they have those protections
there but we've known about this for a
long time why can't why is it the
Catholic hospitals continue not to
perform abortions why is it that
adoption agencies continue to insist on
Catholic doctrines and without a problem
it's because there's no violation of
federal or state law what you have here
is an intent the intent is to intimidate
to bully to get them to capitulate and
so if you get some weak kneed Catholics
like you do in Massachusetts which is
not exactly a very known for their
strong Catholic opinions of why we're
gonna win you ever hear from those
Catholics and Massachusetts that's good
I'd like to hear from them do all right
thanks so much bill